from montreal to miami
and you keep going back to montreal and
you're not staying in miami it's a visit
so tell us why
obviously you have an incredible emperor
i mean i'm sorry you have a great leader
in your country
he's a fantastic guy fantastic so why
does he keep bringing you back to
montreal is it by force is there certain
things that we don't know about that
he's threatening you
why why is that extortion tell us about
it no i honestly it's because of the
golden handcuffs of being a 10-year
professor
so you know when so for those for your
listeners you may not know tenure is a
wonderful thing right because it allows
you to have the protection to be able to
do the things that i do right imagine if
the university could have fired me for
any tweet or any paper that i published
that they didn't like so tenure in
spirit is a great thing because
otherwise irreverent professors who are
not or part of the orthodoxy would never
feel comfortable to be able to say the
things they want to say
so on that's in that sense tenure is
great how do you reach tenure and just
take its amount of time
hours right so after you've you you get
your first professorship you have a
certain number of years where you have
to build a dose here the dossier
consists of three elements what have you
published so research teaching and
service
the most important part is the research
how many papers have you published how
much they've been cited how influential
have you been as an academic and then it
goes in front of a tenure committee
and they decide either they're going to
fire you you have one year to leave so
you're not going to be granted tenure or
if they grant you tenure you're
permanent forever you could never be
fired unless you decide to quit
so tenure is
so it's great in that sense but on the
other hand it makes you risk aversive
because if you want to leave you're
always in the backdrop thinking i've got
this professorship for life and you know
it takes a while to build your academic
career you have to have a lab you have
to have graduate students here
so it kind of weighs you down uh so that
even though in spirit i very much would
like to be making the move to the united
states i just got killed with horrific
taxes which we can talk about it's been
about five six weeks i've been walking
around in a days
unable to understand how the mathematics
of the money that i started with and
what i ended up with how we can go from
a to b
so i'm desperate to leave guys but uh we
have young children so that even makes
me a bit more risk aversive if our
children were grown already
would be a lot easier to say screw
tenure i'm moving to
to miami that makes sense and if you if
you would you would leave most likely to
a south florida type of location oh 100
i mean historically i would have been a
socal guy i lived in
i was a professor at university of
california irvine for a few years i have
a lot of family there every summer we go
back to newport beach this in a week
we'll be going back to newport beach but
then the taxes and the wokeness
in california is not that much better
than where i am now in quebec and so
texas of course and southern southern
florida have sort of become there's like
i don't know like in in miami we have
little havana where all the cubans hang
out right i don't know if it's official
but here in hollywood florida i want to
call it like little quebec is that true
oh my god all the french canadians are
down here in the winter you don't know
that yeah i mean i know that there are a
lot of backers down here i didn't know
it wasn't that specific specifically
right there's snow birds right there oh
yeah every six months guy comes up to me
at church he says you know canadians own
500 000 properties in florida yeah what
is that he says canadians own because
he's from county says
500 000 properties in florida i believe
it by the way when he's talking about
tenure you know what the first thing
that comes to my mind you've been very
vocal about twenty percent of the bottom
half of teachers 20 of teachers on the
bottom thirty percent thirty percent
need to be fired absolutely how do you
grapple that with ten cause all teachers
have tenure of support but what he's
saying is very interesting because
a guy with his views
in a woke environment should get fired
oh i wouldn't have left in five minutes
well this is when tenure backfires on
them on the walk but but here's my
question for you how did did jordan
peterson get fired and wasn't he ten
years long he didn't get fired so with
george what happened with jordan is that
when the gender pronoun stuff happened
he actually reached out to me before he
became jordan peterson of great fame and
he he knew of my show
and he knew that i was very irreverent i
wasn't an orthodox car so he reached out
to me he said look you know i don't
think many people are going to be
willing to be talking to me especially
in academia can i come on your show
that's how we became friends
how many years ago was that this was
2016 maybe or so this isn't crazy long
ago no six years ago and you're in
mcgill and he's in toronto i studied at
mcgill for a bit then i woke up at
cornell but i'm at concordia
there are four universities in montreal
two french to english i'm one of the two
english ones and he was where he was at
university of toronto toronto he didn't
get fired he
he retired
and i think he retired i mean i don't
want to speak for him but i mean i we're
very good friends i know him well uh i
think it became untenable for him to
stay in academia especially given the
amount of other things he's got on and
in a sense i face a bit of a similar
dilemma notwithstanding the tenure you
know i could turn on my
laptop and reach 100 000 people or i
could sit in a classroom for 13 weeks
and reach 30 kids and i don't mean to
denigrate it's teaching is very
important i love it and it's part of my
dna but at one point when you've got the
opportunities that someone like jordan
or myself have
it becomes that much more painful to go
through the grind of the daily life of a
professor
so the research is still wonderful i
still love the idea of doing scientific
research and so on but the
administration how slow things move you
know we will hold a meeting to decide on
setting up a task force to have a
committee to decide on whether we're
going to have coffee in the faculty
lounge so we've just spent six months
and probably 500 000 of professor salary
to decide i mean literally on whether
we're going to have coffee the coffee
task force the coffee task force that
sounds interesting very important yeah
very important so pat is not like coffee
in his offices so we had to set up a
task force here just to implement coffee
true story so it's very slow it's
so for someone like me very
entrepreneurial very fast moving uh it
becomes a bit of a grind so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]